how it started how it's going welcome to
the heavy spoilers show i'm your host
paul
aka baby yolo and i'm so hyped to talk
about season two of the mandalorian
it's been a long time coming in a galaxy
far far away
and if you want a quick catch up just
before we get into it then make sure you
watch our season one recap which will be
linked in the description
anyway i think i can safely say that
this is the best episode in the show's
history
and we start with mando going to meet an
absence known as gorkharesh
after the creed of navarro was wiped out
by moff gideon's forces
mando has been attempting to track down
other mandalorians in the galaxy
and through gore he learns of one on
tatooine who lives as a martial
in the village of mospelgo mando wants
to find his kind in order to use them to
chart a path through the network of
covets
and this will allow him to reunite baby
odor with the jedi
now this introduction and well the
episode itself
is packed with easter eggs and amazing
reveals
we see the pair wandering through the
streets and notice graffiti on the wall
that looks like c-3po
as well as a stormtrooper that has been
crossed out
to the right also appears a rebel symbol
as well as what could be
darth vader's mask and some jawas the
bouncer at the nightclub is a twilike
and we also see that the two fighters
are gamoreans using electrified stone
axes
korash actually shoots the big more
intimidating one
basically cheating in order to win and
this thematically sets up the overall
arc of the entry
in which mano must use his smarts to
take down a giant krait dragon
is that a reach it is now anyway goal
wants nothing more than mando's best
guard armor
and we later see this mirrored in mando
when he tries to take back the armor of
boba fett from the marshall on mos pelgo
we learn that since the mandalorians
have started to die out
that best scar has become infinitely
more valuable
and thus gore has been harvesting it
from mandalorian hives that are pocketed
throughout the galaxy
gore and his crew turn their guns on
mando but he manages to defeat them
quickly by using the whistling birds
from season 1.
mando strings up the character and
promises not to kill him if he hands
over the info
but he leaves him hanging for the wild
dogs in the area and it's the perfect
way to start the entry
cut to tatooine and mando revisits the
hangar from episode 5 of season 1.
here he reunites with pelimoto and her
pit droids
and we also see the return of a big star
wars character
that is r5 if you cast your mind back to
a new hope
r5 was actually the droid that luke
bought but due to its bad motive
he settled on r2d2 instead there
actually exists a fan theory that r5
is the true savior of the galaxy and
that he was aware of just how valuable
r2d2 really was
and self-sabotaged in order to fulfill
his destiny
i'm not joking either whether you
believe that or not which i definitely
do
it's great to see it back and pally
gives mando a speeder bike
as he heads out to mos palgo mando camps
with some tuscan raiders
and also comes across some one frats as
he enters the village
i think they want rats anyway uh the
design changes every three minutes so
let me know if there's something else
now we learned that moss pelgo was a
mining settlement
that dated back before the empire took
over after the destruction of the second
death star
the village was raided by the mining
collective and kyle played by timothy
oliphant
only managed to barely escape when
wandering in the desert he was found by
some
jawas and using one of the
micro-transaction tanks from battlefront
2 he bought boba fett's armor and
returned to the village to take out the
collective
since then he's taken care of the
village himself and become its marshal
now your first question probably is how
do the jawas get the armor
well we learn at the end of the episode
that boba fett
is actually alive and he was likely the
boots that we saw approaching fenix
shand at the end of episode 5 in season
1.
as for how he survived in pretty much
every version of the character's
resurrection he came out the same way
however for this breakdown we're going
to be focusing on the tale of boba fett
by jd montgomery this book was published
in 1996
and it pretty much centers around how
fat escaped the sarlacc
now upon landing in the creature fett
awakened the consciousness within it
which we learn was one of its first
victims a choi
known as susejo because he was one of
the first creatures that the sarlacc
ever ate
his mind melded with the pit and it was
as much him as he was it
the chai had pretty much become its
brain and over millennia it had existed
by
injecting its prey with neurotoxins and
then it slowly digested them with its
stomach acids
that was able to communicate with it
telepathically and during this time
he learned of its past fett knew if he
was able to fool cecho
that he could escape and thus he began
to enact his plan
fett tricked the creature into wrapping
itself around his jetpack
which then exploded hurtling him free of
the monster's tentacles
using a concussion grenade he was able
to escape through a wall in the creature
and the rest is history now whether they
go this route or not we don't know
but it's been in the law for so long i
think that they're gonna stick to it
olly fan pretty much looks like a
cosplayer version of the character
but you know what for a good minute i
was hoping that he was actually the real
bobber
now the martial storyline sort of plays
on some of the expanded universe
and in that others did adopt the armor
even a sheriff at one point that fett
had to be in order to get it back
we could talk about that forever but i
just want to focus on the episode for
now
now we get our first hint that he isn't
a real mandalorian when he removes his
helmet
and he and mando almost go head to head
until their fight is broken up by the
arrival of a krait dragon
which we learn has been terrorizing the
village feasting on banthas it's caused
havoc in the area
and crait dragons are actually a big
part of star wars
mythos you've probably seen their
skeletons dotted about tatooine
and these large carnivorous reptiles
have been hunted for millennia
due to the valuable pills that exist
within their bodies the mandalorians
themselves have a long and rich history
and kailand and joran make a deal to
team up in order to take it down
i love how baby yoda pretty much spends
this episode hiding in pots on its crib
and yeah it's it's still as cute as ever
even though it's one year older
now they head out to where it lives and
kyle actually rides on top of what looks
like anakin's pod racer engine from the
phantom menace
it's seen better days and kyle has
modified this into a speeder
which hints to his scavenging
capabilities whilst traversing they
wander into tuscan territory
and are almost attacked by their dogs
but as we know
mano can talk to them and thus they
instead settle for the night
their camp looks just like how it did an
attack of the clones
and i love how we truly got to see
another side to them
tuscan raiders are often portrayed by
the fake news media
as vicious savages however put your
prejudices to the side
have some of their crap drink and let
the good times roll
see he's not he's not throwing a weapon
up he's partying
now the tuscan riders too want to take
down the dragon and everyone
just wants to team up and kill it this
is sort of where the jaws similarities
come thick and fast i feel
as not only does the dragon swim below
the sand
we also have a scene in which a tuscan
raider almost drops an explosive tank
you might remember in jaws that the main
character martin brodie
almost dropped an air tank and quinn
snapped at him telling him how explosive
it was
this was of course setting up how they
would kill the great white by shoving
the tank in its mouth
and it's very much doing the same thing
here although it was very obvious that
this was gonna play into the end as they
pointed it out so much
but you know what yeah i was loving the
episode so much that i didn't even mind
they also attach ropes to the beast in
order to try and pin it down
but these proved to be pretty futile as
they did in the film
now the squad head out and the episode
actually switches to imax for the
confrontation
if you have a 4k tv with dolby vision
then
you'll know how good this looked and i
was absolutely blown away
by just how phenomenal it was mano gets
thrown into his own fighting pit in
order to take it out
and this sort of mirrors the arena at
the beginning
i'll stop reaching anyway mando kills
the beast by letting it eat him
and a bantha strap with explosives and
he blasts his way out of its body with
an electrified rifle
before blowing it up from the inside out
the village is free
the sam people get their pill amando
heads back to the ship
with vet's armor it's at this point and
i knew i knew they weren't going to do
it i knew as soon as i seen that double
sunset
that fat would appear looking over it
and i tell you what i i was buzzing he
obviously wants his armor back more than
anything
and i think the reason he hasn't gone
after the martial is because he might
not be equipped to deal with him
from what we see of his weapons now
binary sunsets are of course synonymous
with star wars
i think this moment is very much calling
back to luke doing it in a new hope
either way i was so glad to see phet
back and it's amazing that we now have
it officially confirmed that he survived
i say officially but you know what this
could also be a misdirect
and the character may not be fed and
instead it could be captain rex
we know that django was cloned and that
all these clones look the same
so it could be a number of characters
however
due to the age i am leaning more towards
fair especially with the way that the
armor plays such a big part in this
entry
obviously he was a massive character in
the star wars saga
and going forward i think there's a lot
that they can do with him i actually
want to see him and mando team up
but he may well want to fight the
character in order to claim the bounty
that's on baby oda's head
it's going to be interesting to see what
route they go but
what an incredible episode that was and
it's got me so hyped for the rest of the
season
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the episode so make sure you
comment below and let me know
if you enjoyed this video then please
check out our breakdown of the 81 best
easter eggs in lovecraft country which
is going to be linked at the end
we go over the entire season so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more
don't forget we're giving away three
copies of the marvel phase one box set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of october so make
sure you get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat who's on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul and
i'll see you next time take care
peace
you